seventy thousand of the most enraged
African bees rise up in a black cloud
around me
I woke up into the back of the village
and Simon [ __ ] is the village beekeeper
he says okay I can take your beekeeping
next morning I meet him Simon and I
start heading towards the hive Simon
gets out his crowbar and he cranks the
lid off and 70 000 of the most enraged
African bees rise up in a black cloud
around me
one bee found my weak sock area and the
shimmering swarming dark Mass around my
head it's stopped for a second and then
as one the bees went to my ankles and
then he runs back and he starts beating
me with the branch they're still all
around me I say Simon it's not working
it's not working he says okay I will get
the smoker going and I just the thought
ran to my head like a little late for
that and the first blast went right
through the visor of the beekeeping and
kind of into my mouth I said I'm Simon
they're still singing me they're still
seeing me he says oh okay
for your life